[Music]
Harvey Weinstein has been taken into
custody after an ongoing investigation
into allegations of sexual misconduct
he can't confirm that Weinstein turned
himself in to police at the first
precent in New York City early Friday
the New York Police Department shared in
a statement to ET quote Harvey Weinstein
was arrested processed and charged with
rape criminal sex act sex abuse and
sexual misconduct four incidents
involving two separate women adding the
arrest and ensuing charges are the
result of a joint investigation between
the NYPD and the Manhattan district
attorney's office last year multiple
women came forward accusing the 66 year
old star of sexual assault and at the
time
Weinstein denied accusations against him
quote mr. Weinstein has further
confirmed that there were never any acts
of retaliation against any women for
refusing his advances the movie mogul
appeared in court following his arrest
and was arraigned on sex crime charges
Weinstein's attorney says he is pleading
not guilty and fully expects to be
exonerated
[Music]